okay so we're going to continue on the
same topic one rented stock so I'm going
to be talking though more I'm going to
shift the focus at least the beginning
of my talk on the underlying properties
of these protocols so this is based on
recent and ongoing works with one guy
Ryan Nichols Barnardo's euros panic
attack was hong sheng co and Vasilisa
guess so brockton protocols with us who
already know like introduced with the
white paper of bitcoin are with Nakamoto
in 2008 and variants of the protocol
were also claimed by a cabal to himself
like to be related to the consensus
problem or to the business in general
problem as he stated in in a forum I in
2008 they motivated in a few years they
raised a lot of interest and motivated
also analysis work so it was me some
analysis work by Decker but ahora Miller
labriola alcira that pointed to the
interesting properties that these
protocols may have so there are many
questions that remain importantly what
are the probable properties of this
protocol and in what sense do the
implement a robust transaction ledger I
mean if you want what is a robust
transactional ledger and what is the
connection with a consensus problem
which seems to be the core problem that
seems to be related to what this
problems try to achieve so these are the
motivational questions for the first
part of the talk which i'll tell you on
about some recent and ongoing results so
in recent paper doing work with one guy
Ryan Nichols Leonardo's we called we
called it a Bitcoin backbone and Allison
application and what we call the Bitcoin
backbone is basically an abstraction of
the blockchain protocol which is at the
core on of of Bitcoin so I'll tell you a
little bit about our model the this
obstruction of the Bitcoin protocol and
what we are able to prove
on about this protocol so first I'm
going to start with the model which we
call it the cube bounded setting so this
is a model that is inspired from
multi-party computation synchronous
multi-party computation to be precise
and the idea is that time is divided in
round and you have n parties two of
which are controlled by the adversary
there is a random Oracle that the part
is it's available to all parties and
what is intrinsic to that model is that
in each round every party has an
allowance of Q queries to the random
Oracle furthermore in every round as
usual parties can communicate with each
other and this is done via a diffusion
mechanism so this is particular to this
setting in particular in this
communication mechanism the adversary
can spoof messages so basically it can
fake the source of every message so
there is no authentication and
furthermore the adversary can generate
an arbitrary number of messages that
means that an honest party that starts
around and looks at its communication
tape has no idea what is the source of
the messages that it receives so there's
absolutely no indication infrastructure
even worse not even n and T are known to
the parties so basically that means that
we cannot apply npc at least in the
sense that we know it right there is no
way that we can apply these protocols
that rely on authenticated channels or
PK yes
well basically it's it's some
communication again that says you put
your message in the air and then is
diffused somehow in the network like
like you would hope in a peer-to-peer
network basically that your message is
just sent to your immediate peers and
then it's propagated and then in the
course of around all honest pay players
are guaranteed to listen to it I to
avoid to in the sense to distinguish the
fact that you don't have direct access
to the parts but you can imagine that
this is a broadcast mechanism I just
want to I just don't make any any claims
about about this so in this model you
can define protocols and this is what we
call the Bitcoin backbone which is an
abstraction of of the Bitcoin protocol
so various features of the protocol
itself are abstracted away and in
particular they are captured by three
functions VR and I which I will explain
what what what is their purpose so the
nice thing is that VR and I are
functions that have to do with what the
protocol intends to do and they can be
abstracted away from the analysis so the
protocol is based on two hash functions
dn.h and all parties they work on a
state that is their local state that has
the following chain like form it's the
chain is made out of blocks like those
and each block has three components SX
and city are now if you have the first
two components and then you take the
third component that you has it again
you get a small Hospital so this T value
is is a parameter which is a great for
the time being you can just imagine that
this is part of the parameters of the
source code the x value is the
interesting value that the block has if
you want this is the contents of the
of the block the s value is the hash of
the previous block so you see it's like
it's loaded into the next block and the
city r-value is a value that really
doesn't matter but it's important
because this is what makes this whole
hash to be less than T so basically you
want to find the city of value so that
the hash is small now if you look at
this whole thing the values that are
stored in this chain should satisfy a
predicate so V so this is this function
V which is a predicate and basically
says this sequence of values make sense
the nice thing is that we don't have to
specify that so you can define this
protocol for any v so if you like a
certain predicate you think like this is
the change I would like to make you can
instantiate this and actually in our
applications will have a lot of
associations and you can think of
Bitcoin actually of instantiating V as
checking the validity of transactions
and you can think of X as a block of
transactions but we don't care about
this at all yes you know CTR is just a
value that will make the hash small well
small I mean smaller than done one what
is supposed to be so it's like a smaller
than you're supposed to be so instead of
being 256 bits it starts with the signal
sub 0 so it's smaller so this is what i
mean i would say smaller as an integer
actually i mean this this would be the
right way to to mean it city re i will
change yes so every blog will have its
own city are ya is it important that you
talk about functions as opposed to any
present age that you could have to lie
to yeah I guess you could you could try
to define it in some broader way but we
will keep that description because this
fits exactly this this thing so I
imagine you principle you could imagine
something else however like you analyze
this and random Oracle model it makes
sense that these objects are hash
functions so so what happens I within
around the players that are running this
protocol
they get this insert instructions from
the environment so imagine there's an
environment that does them you insert
this x value so so what do they do is
they take this insert values from the
environment and they somehow come up
with what they would like to put into
their state and when they decide to put
this let's say X I plus 1 they try to
make a new block by basically getting
the hash of the previous block getting
the x value passing it through the G
hash function and then trying
repetitively to find a city r value that
satisfies that this whole thing has a
small hash so this is how you extend the
blockchain or the chain so when they
succeed basically they manage to extend
the change so they added here and then
they propagated to all the other players
via this basically unreliable anonymous
broadcast this diffusion mechanism that
they have now as they work in the course
of around a player will get these
suggestions from other parties and it
will decide to adopt them following this
simple rule so basically when you are
working on this thing and you listen to
that you will see which one is longer at
least in this simple obstruction and
you'll say yeah this is better so I'm
going to just go with a longer chain yes
they start from yeah so that's there are
some things that they start from the
same place precisely so but this is
basically let's say I'd like a setup so
in their source code they say oh every
oil change will start from let's say
this quote unquote Genesis block
it's actually like right here so finally
whenever a player is asked to interpret
here chained it will apply this our
function which will read all these X
values and provide an interpretation on
so this also it's an
application-specific so now you can see
like this functions vrn I they are
coming from this side so basically our
is the function that interprets the X
values v's the function that validates
them like they make sense and I is the
value that decides what is the right
thing to put inside so is the insertion
this is the reading and this is the
validation so here are the two
properties that we define and we prove
about this protocol in the model in this
cube bounded setting so the first
property we call it common prefix and
informally says if two players prune a
sufficient number of blocks for their
from their change they will obtain the
same prefix and the second property will
prove is chain quality which informally
states that any large enough chunk of
honest players chain will have some
blocks from the owners players so and we
show that this property's basically are
essential for obtaining good properties
of this for the applications of this
protocol
he cannot stop the diffusion of honest
messages you can insert yourself
precisely yes now it's a synchronous
model so in every round every honest
player is granted to listen to the other
ones players but what is different to
the standard model is that the other
side can flood like this diffusion
mechanism so there's absolutely no bound
to how many messages he can put in so in
the common prefix property basically the
idea is that you can see the owner's
players that build this block chains but
somehow if you take the combined view it
will look like this sort of cauliflower
like peace we're like it starts the same
and then like Forks but it Forks at the
end I mean at least this is the intended
property that we want so here's a
glimpse of the theorem about the common
prefix property so if we abstract us
alphabet that the expected proof-of-work
solutions in around and we take F to be
the sum of it which is like how many
proof of work you can get in one round I
we will require F to be quite small not
tiny by quite small so basically that
means that in a single round you are not
expected to actually to get a solution
so you have to go for a number of rounds
till you manage it then we're going to
introduce a notion which is called
uniquely successful around and it's
going to be the essential resource of
the owners parties as it will turn out
in the proof so basically uniquely
successful round is around that just one
honest player manages to get a solution
so by nature if there is just one honest
player that advances this is an
opportunity for the onus players to
converge that's essential and based on
these parameters we we prove the
following theorem which essentially
establishes the common prefix property
with probability 1 minus exponential in
K where K here is the number of blocks
that you prove from from the chain now
this this in order for the theorem to
hold it has some assumptions so
basically this says this gamma value
which is the rate of these uniquely
successful rounds is bigger than lambda
beta where lambda is a parameter would
satisfies this
quadratic and lambda and gettin betta is
the power of the adversary remember that
gamma is alpha minus alpha square so
it's very close to the honest players
but it's a little bit less so somehow
the owners players have to pay the price
of being distributed whereas lambda we
would like it to be as close to one if
we're going to get this fifty percent
guarantee of bitcoin with we might be
able to do as long as this look at this
quadratic as long as this f is very
close to zero so as f gets close to zero
we can choose lambda to be very close to
one and still satisfy this quadratic so
this this is essential in this and this
analysis yet so f is the expected proof
of work of all parties bad and good in
there in there yes the tents oh yeah you
so go back at most K blocks before you
hit the common trunk yes quite so
actually the same of the theorem it
means the opposite so the chance of
trans fats Wilfork with purple bility
this yeah thank you yeah lambda from
this third way can you sort of solve for
lambda and move it from the terms they
pay it is what is land is not a yeah
it's not it's not essential it never
appears in ever happens in the protocol
but it's here to show the dependency on
F so so basically you could substitute
with some complex expression on F which
basically will allow you will allow
gamma to go very close to beta as long
as f is small give me like one plus some
small sum function of n sum function of
f and as f goes to close to zero then
then basically this coefficient is going
to be club going closer to two one which
is what we would like right so we would
like we would like lambda to be a very
close to one it's just going to look a
little slightly uglier but or I don't
know I guess it depends on your point of
view like what I Glee is but
yes either way to add incentives
incentives to this kind of game and then
claim that the same theorem holds if the
majority is rational or something like
that this is no this oh so this is not
what we're trying to do here so I think
incentives would be would be definitely
would complicate things in in a
substantial way so this is the the
interpretation of this theorem says if
for whatever reason there is an honest
majority that believes that it should
run the source code of Bitcoin then as
long as they are in majority they will
converge to a unique view but this does
not judge the rationality of their
decision so this is let's say the
standard cryptographic model people are
parties are either honest or malicious
and see what were the reasons why it's
so hard to extend this to rational
players well because you would have to
define this we would have to define like
first of all the utility which is by
itself there is not simple how to do and
then like analyzing the protocol in this
census is quite hard is actually
something is an ongoing worker and I
have parallel which are not going to say
much right now but it's it's it's quite
tricky to get to get a proper definition
of it even like the problem so the same
quality property on the other hand talks
about how good is the chain so you are a
party you look at your chain what is the
source of these blocks that you have
there are they coming from the adversary
or are they coming from from the honest
parties and one we prove again for the
same lambda parameter as before is that
if you look at any sequence consecutive
sequence of L blocks then the ratio of
honest blocks is going to be 1 minus 1
over lambda with probability
overwhelming in the in the length L so
this parameters are the same as before
and this is not very optimistic theorem
in some sense observe that if if lambda
goes to one this thing goes to zero so
it's it's not great but at least it says
that you're going to find some honest
blocks there may be one but not much the
world so gamma is there is basically
very close to the honest players power
not quite because it's alpha minus alpha
square where alpha is the onus players
hashing power and alpha square is
basically something like the price they
have to pay for being distributed so
that's a lot like intuition behind this
better is the bad guys and then you
would like Lundell be close to one to
argue that basically this fifty percent
thing so honest majority basically like
if lambda is to for example you're going
on sixty-six percent honest thirty-three
percent dishonest etc so unfortunately
this is no very good right so for
example we would like let's say if you
would like fifty percent of your chain
to be coming from the honest part is
there is no way to get lumber to be one
basically you have to set lambda to be
too and then you don't own as majority
is not enough you would want to have
two-thirds honesty in the system so
that's bad and what we proved is that
this is tight actually this is a
variation the tightness of the theorem
cultural variation of selfish mining
which was a very nice result of a young
sailor that actually looked at some
rational aspects of the protocol here we
don't need that sort of the rational
aspect of their work but basically it's
an attack that says that the bad guys
can flood the change of the owners
parties so okay so what are the
applications so they the first
application we're going to look isn't
better than agreement so what what is
beyond agreement is a protocol where n
parties would like to produce a common
value so that you have to proper this
agreement and validity agreement means
that all on this part is technically the
same value validity is that this value
is basically one of their own values and
specifically if they start with the same
value this should agree on that value so
if you think about in the binary case
this basically says if everyone is party
starts with one they're gonna agree on
10 they're gonna agree with zero so but
this is like a stain setting for for
visit an agreement is a setting where
it's completely anonymous has not been
considered in the literature that much
there was a work by Okung in 2005 and
basically no efficient algorithm was
known forbidden agreement in the pure
anonymous setting and actually the
possibility result was shown in this
work so basically what we show is that
in some sense VidCon can be used to
solve this problem but it's not simple
so first of all it was Nakamoto himself
where posted in the forum a protocol
that basically works like that and
parties start building a blockchain that
way I said inserting their input so
let's say you have your input is 0 user
say I'm going to build a blockchain full
of 00000 I do that this is what I do
another part litter has one says I'm
going to be the block same with 1111 so
what happens whenever you find the
solution and you extend your chain you
send it to everybody else now let's say
you have a chain that has three zeros
three blocks with zero and you find it
saying it's an comes that has 4 watts so
you say ok I'm going to get the longer
chain so that's the proper code you go
on for some time and at the end when
this is long enough you say my output is
the value that is contained inside the
blockchain it's just a single value
right it's a very simple protocol and
this is a protocol that that there was
this claim that in the Komodos post that
basically blockchain solve consensus so
this is not quite right it's very easy
to see that there is this protocol does
not satisfy the lid Utley with
overwhelming probability and the reason
for that is is is when the adversary you
know is likely in the first round or the
first couple of rounds to get like a
block with a zero he can switch all
honest guys from one to zero so you can
get validity but with let's say no
negligible probability but we would like
but it with overwhelming probability so
can we do something smarter yes we can
do something smarter so instead of doing
this we can have all parties put their
input on the blockchain but they never
they should never abandon their input
let's say I'm going to put this
zero because I that was my input so I
put a maker block with zero then I
listened from you block two blocks with
one that's fine i take your two blocks I
accept them they are longer than mine so
it's 11 then I'm going to put my zero
after your to once and I'm going on like
this so now as you can see like this
block chain has both input zeros and
ones at the end what I'm going to have
even as I'm going to extend this chain
let's say for 2k positions I'm going to
throw away the last k to cut the
cauliflower at the top and then keep the
trunk which I hope is the same and then
I'm going to run majority does this work
well it works but I need one third bound
on the adversary because this is tight
because of the chain quality the same
quality property i told you is not that
good so i would like to maintain or its
majority in the in the trunk and in
order to do that the artists are should
be bounded by one third yes so the
pruning is that you would like agreement
so you would like to make sure that when
you run majority the honest players will
be running majority in basically the
same set of values yeah so on the other
hand you would like majority and then
you would like to show chain quality
would actually provide you with validity
but not quite right yeah I mean like you
there's just no protocol that could ever
be better than that or its type no no
I'm just saying it's tied for this
particular protocol so if your logic is
this that's it so we would do better
actually afterwards but requires more
work yeah
with the possibilities of us was how
cold it can be good but then I will show
you that despite same quality sucks
basically we can still do it correctly
so but you need to do something smarter
so we'll show you this how much time to
have seven minutes okay real seven
minutes real time soon minutes okay not
blockchain time which can actually
fluctuate a bit alright so then I'm
going to be a bit about it what is the
robustness action leger so robust as
actual laser is a protocol basically
that satisfies two properties a
persistence says if the transaction is
deep enough in the ledger then it will
be reported by all owners parties of the
same location so basically if if one
party says the transaction is here then
everybody will say the transaction is
there so that's persister surprise the
transactions stay they are sticky there
in the ledger and the other is liveness
so basically says if all honest part is
no way transaction well it will find its
way in the ledger deep enough so it will
get deep enough so it will stay so these
are like I would say to minimal
properties you would like to have from
something that is a transaction ledger
the good thing is that we prove that
based on common prefix and same quality
you can get these properties with
honours majority so this fifty percent
thing works so if basically the backbone
protocol will give you will have
resistance and liveness up to fifty
percent as advertised so what about
consensus why we were stuck with a
one-third before so agreeing on
transaction does not imply consensus
there is raised the source of
transactions is not guaranteed just
because you can agree on me that's an
intuitive level but that's the that's
the problem right so just because you
agree on transaction that doesn't mean
that is guaranteed so chain cult is too
low the owners party transactions can be
flooded by the adversary so what about
this idea so instead use transactions
that have proof of work themselves so
basically transactions now will have
proof of work the block chain will have
proof of work and now that's good
because if you have honest
jority then you know that eventually the
honest players will produce more
transactions that the bad guys because
now the transactions themselves have
proof of work so this sounds like a nice
idea this is like our second visit a
great protocol which I'm not going to
tell you but I told you the main idea
which unfortunately has a big caveat so
the problem is now that you are using
proof of work for two different things
one thing is to make the blockchain the
other is to donate the transactions to
put in the blockchain and the problem is
that these two things do not compose the
adversary can sift hashing power from
the one to the other and basically
security breaks it's like a composition
problem which we solve it with an idea
which we call two for one pulse which
unfortunately i will not have the time
to explain it every time I give this
talk like this is the slider say I don't
have time to explaining which
unfortunately this like one of them very
neat ideas of the paper but you can ask
me like afterwards so just one word
about transaction speed versus security
I'm just going to go rush and just show
you this diagram so this is upcoming
work improving the bounds so I'm just
going to point to this this is basically
a plot that shows what is the
relationship between the expected rounds
is going to take you to make one block
and this is what is the strongest
adversary you can tolerate so it's a
speed versus security plot so now if you
look at the probable security bounce
from the uroclub paper it's here so
basically probable security is
underneath unknown territory here so
basically in the grid paper what we
prove is that when f goes to one
basically you get one proof of work per
round very fast basically you have no
probable security at all and then it
goes like this so in a work that comes
now we are improving this bounce very
significantly so we have more probable
security actually for the protocol and
this is a good thing because there are y
bit
has an expected rounds per block very
the right-hand side of this diagram
there are other coins litecoin ethereal
met cetera that actually they are much
to the left of this diagram so for
example theorem is here right so you see
like you know this is critical so it's
critical to understand security for solo
actually we also analyze the ghosts rule
and we have a probable security for this
variant of nakamoto's longest chain
winds rule so God means greedy heaviest
observed subtly and you can think of
this as a variation of of the main
blocks in protocol of Nakamoto I'm not
going to explain how it works but they
the main it's also famous because it's
implemented in ethereal okay and I'm not
going to say much more so let me go now
and finish with connecting with two runs
its talk fair and pc based on those
action later so let me go up now and
test tell you some recent results on
that so we we saw synchronistic fairness
violation with put by computation
perhaps we can have a protocol that
compensates the honest parties when this
happens and there is like previous work
which showed that this idea can be quite
useful still there is many interesting
questions in this direction most
importantly how can we model embassy
with furnace in the sense of
compensation what about a composition of
these protocols and what about not just
fairness but robustness in other words
can we have guaranteed up with delivery
if there is no output delivered then we
can get compensated so this is like a
stronger property than furnace so here
is some results which actually they are
the preprint is available this is joint
work with hong sheng co and Vasilisa cos
we have a new model for fairness q
furnace which is basically modeling or
furnace in the existence assuming the
existence of a global functionality gee
that has a public state s and a queue
predicate and the idea is that we define
in this variant of the
you see model a wrapper functionality
that takes a fair functionality and
transforms it to a Q fair functionality
that basically works like that whenever
furnace is violated the wrapper will
hold if the predicate Q becomes true so
basically this is a rapper functionality
in the spirit of the garage mckenzie
prabakaran young resource furnace model
but but introducing this connection with
a global functionality where there it
was just resource-based so the nice
thing about this is that we have a
global functionality which is a clock
and a ledger so basically the
synchronized ledger functionality the
good thing is that it captures this
functionality all these out coins
bitcoin theorem name going light going
things that you might use as a ledger so
can be captured as a global
functionality and based on that you can
define fairness and in a standard way
without having to resort to Turing
machines that have these additional
features like coins saves etc so it's a
clean model which is basically has a do
you see like composition theorem and
it's possible to define fairness in this
model and formalize of all these
protocols that were mentioned in ranji
stock in a way that they are letting the
standard you see do you see sense so
they are not like special machines right
so you can just think of them as regular
itms that have access to this global
functionality summarizing or finishing
this basically we also have a new
protocol basically protocol compiler
which has some interesting features most
importantly it achieves robustness with
compensation so basically robotics in
the sense after the initial set of
transactions is guaranteed to produce
output or compensate and it can do that
in a constant number of rounds so this
is a feature that goes beyond
this previous protocols were only fair
with compensation so you can do better
in this sense so basically thank you
very much for your attention you have
any questions I'll be happy to hear